J'ai de mauvaises nouvelles que mes parents
rendent visite quand maintenant est-ce que je vis ici,
certainement pas que nous ayons des relations sexuelles, je n'allais pas
tout mentionner, d'accord, ne pensiez-vous pas
que cela arriverait si
nous revenions quand vous avez de la compagnie  Tim en
fait euh
vit ici vraiment ouais mais pas de sexe oral je
te promets à mon cher fils que ça
va sembler étrange les hommes de la famille
peuvent voyager dans le temps
Wow est-ce bien une réaction est Inuk je
pense que j'ai gonflé pour baiser mais c'était  les
années soixante-dix tu vas dans un endroit sombre
pense au moment où tu vas et tu t'y
retrouveras Jim en fait ouais
perdant
tu ne dis pas mais je vis dans la
chambre d'amis nous n'avons pas de chambre d'
amis sans fond dans  le morceau de rechange de sa chambre
où elle n'est pas en d'autres termes il n'y a
aucun sens
Merci partenaire excusez-moi ça va
être une année compliquée ça va être une
vie compliquée
mais même si ce n'est pas aussi dramatique qu'il le
dit tu ne peux pas  tuer Hitler ou baiser Hélène
de Troie malheureuse